what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Oh members of the Rob core I'm buying a
house I'm actually buying a house and
I'm really really excited about this
because we're a few months out I want to
make some improvements with a few things
a basement so on and so forth but I will
do a house tour once everything's all
said and done there's a room that I want
to put a sauna in like one of those
steam rooms could be really kind of cool
anyway what is up guys what is up yes we
are back with another installment of
Omega and Beyond Omega level characters
a series where we highlight the grossly
overpowered characters that exist in
comic books and in this video we're
gonna be focusing on Marvel's version of
Superman Hyperion the reason why I say
he's Marvel's version of Superman is
because even though Marvel has put out
several characters over the years that
have drawn inspiration from Superman
like the century and blue marvel and
gladiator Hyperion was the first having
been created in 1969 by Roy Thomas and
Sal Buscema
now as we get into a discussion of
Hyperion's origin and his powers it's
going to be impossible to miss the
influence that Superman has on his
character something we have to
understand however is that there have
been several versions of Hyperion that
have appeared throughout his history so
what we're gonna do in this video is
we're gonna try to quickly go over most
of these versions with a brief
description and then we'll get into a
discussion about the only thing you guys
really care about his powers now since
this is not a full-fledged character
explanation there are going to be some
things left out of the histories of each
version covered here undoubtedly there
will be those folks who are like
actually you missed this yes I just told
you we would miss it now I want to give
you an understanding of what the
character is capable of so the primary
version of Hyperion is from earth-712
where he was the last surviving member
of a super-powered alien race called the
Eternals and we'll get into what
specific powers Eternals have here in a
minute and what Hyperion comes to earth
and is raised by the Milton family and
he adopts the earth name of Marcus
Milton he's given a good moral
upbringing and moves to the city of
Cosmopolis where he takes a job as a
newspaper cartoonist he would later go
on to use his powers as a superhero and
join a group of other super-powered
beings called the squadron supreme so
yeah Marvel was being pretty deliberate
here I mean Hyperion is basically
supposed to be a pastiche
Superman as anyone who's remotely
familiar with Superman's origin would
immediately see the similarities between
the two characters now after the
squadron supreme encounter the
Grandmaster one of the elders of the
universe basically the last surviving
member of his own race grandmasters
sought to make a clone of Hyperion on
the main Marvel Universe now grandmaster
was successful in doing this that he
implanted false memories into the clone
leading the clone to believe that he was
an explorer from the planet it reom Lisa
thing as how I was pronounced named zip
Ron and that his home planet had been
destroyed by the first splitting of the
atom on earth basically his planet got
destroyed when humans discovered the
nuclear bomb now this Hyperion vows
revenge on earth and joins grandmasters
team of supervillains the squadron
sinister and the squadron sinister would
battle the Avengers on several occasions
and eventually this version of Hyperion
would do battle with the original
Hyperion from earth-712 their battle as
you probably expect seeing as they're
essentially the same person was pretty
hard fought and actually pretty amazing
which resulted in the earth-712 version
of Hyperion being blinded while as evil
clone for the main Marvel Universe was
killed now there are a few other
versions of Hyperion for example King
Hyperion from Earth 4:02 3 who took over
his home earth killing that universes
versions of Thor Hercules and Galactus
in the process and declaring himself
emperor of that earth we really need to
cover that story oh my god I forgot
about that
we so have to cover that story Hyperion
kills the Marvel Universe there we go
but after he seizes control his subjects
decided that they would rather die than
live under his tyrannical rule so they
detonated a nuclear bomb to destroy
themselves
and their entire world which is pretty
intense the Hyperion of course survived
the explosion and was pulled from his
reality by a race of aliens called the
time breakers to join their Weapon X
team and serve as a nemesis to the time
hopping superhero team known as the
exiles now he would later be defeated by
blue Marvel imprisoned on the raft for
super-powered criminals but after
escaping he was recruited to join the
Thunderbolts before dying at the hands
of man things Bernie touch man thing is
really really weird character that
exists in Marvel Comics Florida is
already a home for like the weirdest
things like Florida man did this but
they have what are called a Florida
Everglades which exists in real life but
in Marvel Comics the Florida Everglades
are actually home to this
interdimensional portal that if you walk
through it you end up in like this
massive labyrinth and you can literally
just start jumping to different
realities it's kind of cool it's
actually how Howard the Duck ended up in
the Marvel Universe back when he first
showed up it was really kind of a weird
situation but finally we come to the
last version of Hyperion which is the
version that you're probably most
familiar with if you've read anything
reason for Marvel Comics which is to say
anything in like the last five years
like any of the lead-up to Secret Wars
and Jonathan Hickman is Avengers and New
Avengers which is where the Hyperion
from Earth one three zero three four
made his appearance in issue number one
this version has a pretty similar origin
to the earth-712 Hyperion but his home
universe was in the path of an incursion
a colliding of two universes whereby
both universes are destroyed and which
served as a main plot point of the
Secret Wars event in 2015 now this newer
version of Hyperion is the sole survivor
of this incursion and is pulled to the
main line Marvel Universe by advanced
idea mechanics basically this rogue
scientific group that was originally
part of Hydra who basically keep him
captive until he's freed by the Avengers
and joins their team now Hyperion would
be killed
battling a wave of the nearly omnipotent
aliens known as the beyonders but was
brought back to the main Marvel Universe
following his recreation after the
Secret Wars event because Marvel failed
to reboot Hyperion would go on to join
the squadron supreme in this new
universe and was most recently seen
among the most powerful characters in
the Marvel Universe trying to repel a
wave of aliens during the events of
secret Empire and so now that we've
covered who Hyperion is or at least the
mini versions of him we can get into
what his powers are and just as his
origin story bears a striking
similarities that a Superman so to his
powers in case you're like not from the
planet Earth
or you're like an alien even though
aliens probably know who Superman is his
Superman gives his powers from the sun's
energy and because IP Rhian is an
eternal his body functions differently
than humans and that it collects cosmic
radiation specifically particles of
light from the Sun and converts them
into energy
basically meaning Hyperion's powered by
the Sun now Hyperion's eternal
physiology also grants him a myriad of
super powers very similar to the super
powers Superman possesses has a lot of
supers first among these is
super-strength and he is
the strongest characters in the Marvel
Universe and I do not take that lightly
I do not say that like oh yeah man he
can punch really hard no he is really
really strong he was able to trade
punches with the Incredible Hulk and
force him back into his human form he
lifted Atlantis from the ocean and flew
the entire city into the sky and was
even able to hold two colliding
universes apart for a short period of
time now truth be told it wasn't like
the whole of the universe's it was
basically the Earth's that were gonna
collide into each other but think about
that for a second Hyperion was able to
push two planets apart it was like hold
them apart from one another that's
pretty insane now in addition to being
one of the strongest characters in the
Marvel Universe he also possesses super
speed durability and stamina he can fly
and his body can convert photons and
energy he doesn't need air water or food
to survive he has a highly enhanced
intellect outclassing the Avengers
computers in calculated a point of
impact of a bomb and can determine the
parentage of someone simply by glancing
at their DNA samples
Hyperion can take a great deal of
punishment due to his superhuman
durability but also possesses a
regenerative healing factor that's so
advanced it actually slows down as aging
not only is he nearly impervious to
physical energy but is immune to any
disease and poisons if I period didn't
sound similar enough to Superman already
he also possesses atomic vision which is
pretty much exactly like Superman's heat
vision which allows him to shoot beams
of energy from his eyes that have been
shown powerful enough to kill namely the
Submariner but doesn't really matter cuz
Namor sucks
so yeah Hyperion is pretty much a direct
copy of Superman at every level but at
least it is a nav x-ray vision right uh
actually he does he does have x-ray
vision so while it's undeniable that
Hyperion is heavily influenced if not
copied basically from Superman that does
not mean that he's not a powerful
character in his own right he's pulled
off some pretty amazing feats just a few
of which we've basically named here so
we really kind of have to classify him
as like an omega-level character I don't
know if he's really beyond omegan level
just because of the fact that he's not
like a universal threat but he's
certainly Onegin level I mean Galactus
could just probably obliterate him but
again we saw an alternate reality
version of them pretty destroyed
Galactus so I guess it depends on what
that we're talking about if we're
talking about King Hyperion then yeah
he's definitely beyond omega-level just
because he was running around killing
cosmic entities but we never really saw
anything in the most recent iteration of
his character that led us to believe
that he was beyond omegat level so he's
one of those weird characters were it's
like he's Omega level but he's also
beyond Omega level depending on which
iteration of the character that we're
talking about but without being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain to make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]